hey Amalia meet Conan and Sona hi oh my
God hey is it Amalia is that how I say
your name it is perfect yeah sometimes
people say Amelia but you say Amalia is
that correct it is yeah my parents found
it in a book um it was Napoleon bonapart
sister's name or something I'm looking
it up now and no it
wasn't you're I think your parents were
just playing a cool trick on you yeah uh
my dad got liquored up and came back
with a joke book an Irish joke book and
there was a Conan in there that's how I
ended up with my name so who knows the
important thing is where are you coming
from right now where are you in this
spinning Blue Marble we call Earth I'm
in New Zealand oh you're in New Zealand
oh incredible yes that's cool and are
you a regular listener to the podcast I
am yeah uh that's very nice to know I
always love it when we reach out to
people in farflung corners of the globe
and tell me a little a little bit about
your life what do you do Amelia what
part of New Zealand are you in first of
all I'm sorry Amalia um can I just call
you suie is that okay are you all right
with Susie all right Susie and you say
you're from the Bronx okay um no
Amalia uh which part of New Zealand are
you from so I'm in a town called Tims um
it is a small town and I'm 20 minutes
away from there in a smaller town called
carape wait you're town is called Tim
Tims t h a m e s okay all right Tims oh
I see I thought it was Tim and it was
near the town of Bruce about about 10
kilometers from David 15 miles south of
Jesse um so uh Tims New Zealand uh and
it's a very small town how many people
you say uh about 400
400 you know I've always thought there'd
be no privacy in a town of 400 people
well there kind of isn't um you do have
to be careful what you talk about
because it goes around so you can't bad
mouth someone else in town because
they're going to hear it pretty much
uhhuh unless you're ready for like a a
fist fight oh oh have you been in many
fist fights Amalia no no I haven't I
think that would be a problem because I
like to trash talk people I like to talk
badly about people behind their back for
me it's a sport it's
fun um the problem is I'm a physical
coward so that would be a problem if I
lived in Tims because I would probably
say mean things about people like oh
look at those shoes you know you find
them in a dumpster that's your idea of a
mean thing to say about someone yeah
those shoes look like they have a high
arch what's his deal you know and then I
think you'd be okay you've got status
con O'Brien that roll out a red C hope
for you I think you'd be the town gossip
for sure yeah I would be the I would be
the town gossip yeah uh I'd be the
Gossip Girl of T's New Zealand dream
every Christmas season it's the same
thing demands for more podcast episode
comes in and we've got to meet those
demands we got to mail out those
podcasts we got to get them in the mail
well guess what with stamps.com all you
need is a computer and printer then
you're ready for that Holiday Rush you
know what I'm saying no remember last
year when we were stuffing podcast into
envelopes and licking them and putting
on the stamps it was crazy in here no
more not with stamps.com they even send
you a free scale so you have everything
you need to get started cuz whenever I
go to mail stuff out I'm like where's my
scale well they got the scale ready
there for you now taking care of orders
on the go is even easier with the
stamps.com mobile app if you need a
package pickup you can easily schedule
it through your stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace in shopping
cart cat your business ready for the
holiday Rush get started with stamps.com
today sign up at stamps.com Conan for a
special offer that includes a 4-week
trial plus free postage and a free
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com Conan
probably start rors just to watch other
people fight yes I would try and get
other people to fight each other I'd say
I'd say Hey Joe is there a guy named Joe
in your town there is I live with one
there you
go I'd say and give me another name of
someone who lives in the town uh my
boyfriend EMT okay I'd say hey Joe I
didn't think it was cool what EMT said
about
you and he'd be like what did he say
about me and I'd say I don't know he
said that uh I don't know your shoe has
a high
arch and then EMT would
say uh I never said that and then I'd
say to EMT well you should hear what
Joe's been saying about you EMT and I
would it would end with both of them
fighting in the town square is there a
town square uh no not it's just a m
Street well listen every Main Street has
a Town Square
so the first thing I would do if I got
to TS is I would organize where a Town
Square would be and I would build it I
would build you a Town Square out of
Lego probably the right size did you say
Lego or liquor liquor would be more fun
but I said Lego well enough liquor and
you're building a lot of stuff out of
Legos yes I will do that I will I will
uh I would that's what I would do I
would be obsessed if I lived in TS I
would be obsessed with there being a
Town Square you need Town Square you
know they had one uh on um Gilmore Girls
and it's where everybody gathered uh
with like a gaze like a gazebo you need
a Gaz you know what a gazebo is right
you need to have a a Town Square it has
to have a gazebo it has to have little
lights people have to be wandering
around in the in the town square and
that's where things get settled don't
you think that would be a good idea for
Ts that would be great we could just
start like an underground fighting ring
at the Gazebo yeah we
got I don't know why you Amalia I don't
know why you went there I never
suggested that we start a fight club
underneath the Gazebo but okay we're
gonna do that now I suppose okay so uh
tell me a little bit about your life
what do you do um so I'm a customer
service agent for a Telco company in New
Zealand um I started out in a call
center and now I'm doing their social
media Pages wait a minute Amalia are you
at work right now no oh yes you are I
work from home no you're totally at work
you're totally working and you said I'll
just put this idiot on hold and I'll
call Conan O'Brien and see if he's
willing to fund a Fight Club underneath
the gazebo in TS is that what you're
doing right now you're work you're
totally working there's someone there's
someone waiting on hold right now
listening to insipid music while uh you
come up with this scheme yeah I'm sorry
it's wow you're you're easy to that was
an easy confession it really was too
easy all right so and you have a
boyfriend I do yes uh let me ask about
him because you need my approval if this
is going to If this relationship is
going to continue well don't you think
of me as kind of a father figure to
Amalia not at all not at you just met
her like five minutes ago David don't
you think I'm kind of a father figure no
Eduardo Father Figure no way okay
getting a lot of nose here Amalia what
do you think am I kind of a father
figure yep and I think
we fighing underground okay good uh well
anyway uh how long have you two been
going out uh about 10 years oh my
goodness my god well okay all right well
I don't know if there are any plans
moving forward but uh that's your
business not mine I wish you nothing but
the best you crazy young people you
thank you very much yeah I would think I
mean if I lived in TS I'm a guy that
likes to have various Affairs on the
side that would be very hard for me
because if there's only 400 people I
think word would get out you know you
know me I'm kind of a lothario yeah you
would plow your way through all 400
people yeah okay it'll be related too so
You' just be like recycling the same
fames well that's pretty much what I
come from so I think man well I do a we
pretty much come from I come from the
temps of
Massachusetts we just live there for
like 200 years and look what happened
we've all got super long Limbs and we
can see in the
dark